and time for is schmidt to come back now
he can rest and heal
westbrook against harris goes adam
aggressive misses gets his own miss
puts it back up and in giving this team
a boost
his energy has been fantastic yeah this
is much needed he's going to have to
watch out for the pump fake because
kyrie
knows how close he's con contesting his
shots
is smith kicks it out to russell
westbrook quick three
and westbrook able to hit it and you
must keep him off offensive glass
because he has a
ton of energy westbrook with the left
he's done so well operating down there
for the wizards stay solid
former teammates from last year in
houston westbrook knocks down his second
three
and now it's a ten point ball game he's
going ten times
full when it comes to scoring making the
extra plays as you see right now
him spacing the floor
[Applause]
beal going at johnson step back got it
first
field goal attempt of the game for
bradley field he's got four points now
westbrook against kyrie irving westbrook
beautiful
move off the glass russell westbrook's
got 15.
so westbrook has responded in a great
way bruce brown stops that back door cut
but it's a steal here by westbrook
westbrook going at harris again 17 now
for westbrook please allow you to get
back in the game
they usually make one to two passes at
max
and then the ball is follows up and the
wizards they love to run
here's beal against brown gets the pick
by lopez and we've got ourselves a tie
game and veal will have a chance to give
the wizards the lead
i'm gonna be durant first if it is but
bradley beal
putting the pressure on the wrist and
now was that a foul
westbrook quickly back the other way 19
first half points for russell westbrook
beal able to knife his way through off
the glass beautiful move by feel he's
got 11.
back up to a nine point brooklyn lead
that's automatic the reason why
he was resigned as a free agent
this summer as russell westbrook
continues to attack the basket
[Applause]
west flipped this time to pull up from
the elbow westbrook's got 23.
that's the confidence you can see the
release
beal all the way to the hoop with the
left beautiful
move by bradley beal there's a dodging
bullet at the bullet not finding guys in
transition especially shooters
fadeaway baseline by 15 now for beal
[Music]
westbrook comes right back with a three
of his zone he's got 26.
westbrook wow difficult angle cut off
along the baseline by luau cabaret
and still finishes for 28 points on the
night
i mean he is in a zone this game
was going to be won by the wizards bench
tonight that was going to be determining
factor
so far so good
[Applause]
deal against shaman goes baseline
finishes with the left
he wanted the add one
[Music]
[Applause]
field fading away
field is now seven of 16. slide his feet
play without fouling and
try and try to contain kevin durant
beal gets all the way to the 21 points
38 consecutive wagner kick
out matthews 4-3 in and out rebound by
hachimura
beal for three that's good the rainbow
three by beal makes it a two-point game
easy catches
[Applause]
westbrook exploding to the hoop russell
westbrook with 33
22 now for irving field
he gets fouled a chance for a
three-point play for beale
and he extends that streak as he is now
at 26 points tonight
five to open up the season that's coming
with
not scoring a field goal in the first
quarter
having two points and now have an
opportunity for his 27th
pointed the line game together on
defense
because kyrie and kd they're not looking
to pass right now in his last next three
minutes
what a difficult shot that was 29
for veal it is a shootout
irving westbrook good box out with the
rebound
here comes westbrook he gets fouled does
he get the roll yes
and and one a chance to cut it to one
i mean once he got the ball in his hands
after this rebound
i mean look at this nothing's stopping
him
that's hall of fame downhill
by not letting joe harris even catch the
ball so you're out of the play
here's beale he attacks the hook and he
gets fouled by irving
he's figured it out he's cracked
pandora's box to score
harris throws it up rebound feel
up ahead here comes westbrook down by
two westbrook
to the hoop with the left
double and he's got 38 points
five point game 12.3 they got to go
quick
[Applause]
beal will pull up for three he hits it
[Applause]
here's brad right here with the pull-up
and great shot
35 for bl two-point game matthews with
the steal
here's westbrook for three hits
you jump by one wow
unbelievable and this was i like right
here look at garrison here
garrison matthews get that to russell
westbrook put a three
i mean did that just happen